okay it's a boy psychobabble here we're
playing this when I left Stillwater for
the Senate I vowed never to forget my
hometown roots that my husband gave his
life defending Stillwater from gang
violence it is my greatest privilege to
honor him with this bridge get cut it
cut it
this is
hence
that's all time for the high spot boys
my [ __ ]
Tesla sales whoever this crew is they
flow pretty damn good that killed Bane's
thugs Calvin Hale who here's the
syndicates a tech dog what he did to
Johnny's funeral that's over the [ __ ]
limit she doesn't care about the rules
of engagement no rules I can work with
that you're not ready to fight The
Syndicate watch us
you just relax Chandi there are others
who hate The Syndicate as much as you do
I will take you to them
can you believe it on my husband's
bridge
no no I will not come down I am heading
back to the hill book an emergency
session god damn it this is war
cut cut cut so you know who were after
picking up a girl named Kenzie
Kensington the deckers are holding her
on a barge on the river what's her deal
Oleg said she was with the FBI are you
[ __ ] me
don't stress she was kicked out so we're
getting a shitty FET I kind of start
hating because we're getting a new girl
are you serious I'm not saying I'm just
saying I'm not jealous
okay oh my god yeah yeah great sexual
tension what got her kicked out Olli
didn't give me all the details but he
made it sound like Kinzie was about to
out the syndicate so the Decker set her
up for fall I hope she's worth the
hassle
only one way to find out you better get
her at bars okay
- farts
what is this show
Oh actually gotta go on the part
can I just go over this like a bathhouse
yeah
a lot of respect
get some scale if I get some space
it's just big crazy looks like the Bleak
line by Christoph Valkyrie we can become
otogi games I can totally enter for Gan
Gan finca conjugate GG baby in Toronto
hey dumpling Oh baby
pom pom pom pom baby Papa Papa people
let me see your penis Kensington yep yes
Titus fantasy if you were sent to kill
me we heard that you know some people
who hate syndicate as much as we do
okay good that's a whole [ __ ] mission
better not be well the winters are
keeping the most at safe word
translation please the de winters are
the twin sisters that run prostitution
and Steelport the most was their
competition so the sisters locked him up
and safe word is just a BDSM Club that
caters to various acts of perversion the
name comes from hope we got it mine's
TCAP I'll get her out of here good good
have fun at the [ __ ] shop
I like him chess
okay let's get to this club let's get to
this club who's calling I Thanks you can
thank me by finding a third person to
help she's gonna call me like one second
one second I said a kink they have at a
place like this some nasty [ __ ] if you
try to stop sorry oh my god you totally
would
let's clean out this one thing all right
quick all right I might see one of these
I just get excited watch watch watch
let's fry those suckers
that guy got very my god now you better
get in baby
if I can check to in charges and out
[ __ ] like vomiting
this is great this is great oh [ __ ] my
[ __ ] okay
you ever liked playing game too much in
there a soul just like you get so
relaxed and into it that your [ __ ]
leg loosens up to some schedules out
that's like probably my top 10 biggest
problems in this room in this first rope
you know okay
oh I like this where do we start looking
shake people down someone's got to know
where they're keeping our boy say I do
this to show that I'm not messing around
I shake I shake things up they call me
the shaker I shake twice when I'm peeing
at the end okay either take me to zimos
or I'm gonna beat your sorry ass
seriously the manager's upstairs Hey no
just take me I've been bad okay
no one pushes me around okay
new slaves are great fun to break
Master I'd like to befoul with what I
did cop tank the manager where is he I
don't know anything I'm just here for a
bachelor party damn it
what sound like that oh look it look at
don't doubt just like old times
you got an angry woman coming at you I
like that I like that okay I didn't know
this is how we're playing it zimos where
is he if I say anything the Dewinter
sisters will cut me off honey I was
thinking of cutting something off too
okay
[ __ ] shot up shut sorry sir
let's do this but just a [ __ ] how do i
how do i sock today's okay I'm gonna
have to bathe in hand sanitizer don't
worry
how are we gonna find zimos look for the
cat in here who isn't excited to be
eating a ball gag or just look for the
guy with a rhinestone Z on his back
Oh goddammit oh well [ __ ] that's
convenient that revive [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is going on there
sorry you know pull us around this is
why you gotta put that image in my head
I'm good angel let's see that's that's
just time to mount a rescue Z so no
saddle up comments either what I like
this guy
that's [ __ ] the [ __ ] are you got
okay
we're not they say the blacker the berry
that used to the fruit
okay I'm spinning I like this guy guy
he's like kinda crazy
he might say my yeah I got yes huh
shut sorry
[ __ ] my cry [ __ ]
no I got a lot of ways it's sad it's
gone yeah I'm making all right yeah yeah
that's a pop some JS there you know
subject Wow
yeah everything's [ __ ] far
but what the [ __ ] is going on here what
the [ __ ] am I supposed to go
taking a [ __ ] helicopter
smack that - smack have that's makeup
okay this is Oleg whereas I like
nowadays I'm not too late to the party
am i there's plenty to go around let's
get in there and find angel angel he's
got 92 got children are one of Lorenz
brutes and you are not one of Cubans
Luchadors but they are protect the man
shall leave this impostor for me
okay where are the rats where they're at
I'm just like
take care peace
not [ __ ]
hey puppy get up there okay oh [ __ ] my
white ass all look good I gotta kill
this [ __ ] suck it suck toes like a
testicle
we care for them flamethrowers
well ladies and gentlemen undisclosed
location is dead and we are at a
crossroads and the question is who will
lead the syndicate to a new era
I'm a viola and Kiki will mr. Lorenz
right hands that I had someone else in
mind
excuse me the syndicate has to answer
for what they did then this time we're
taking the fight to them since we don't
know steel board I brought in some
people who do mrs. Kinsey zimos an angel
the barbarians are at the gate we need a
general not an ambassador calm down
Eddie what did you call me what would
you like us to do kill vane something
anything before I wonder why I keep you
know gets around talk to one of these
guys they'll have things for you to do
it's our time now
nice tents
dicks out for her Rob